so as we get into the Killing Joke part
two what we do here is we pick up with
Barbara Gordon after she's been shot and
the doctor who is examining her says she
has been shot the spine he confirms this
something that we had already thought
and as a result she's completely
paralyzed here the Harvey Bullock speaks
up and says that that Barbara Gordon's
friend Colleen Reese was the one that
had found her they were supposed to be
going to a yoga class together and that
Colleen Reese when she arrived the
apartment I found Barbara Gordon shot
and apparently stripped naked and what
happens here is that Batman asks Harvey
Bullock and the doctor to leave the room
and what happens is that as Batman
begins speaking with with Barbara Gordon
we find out that Barbara Gordon is
absolutely horrified hear the reason
being because this scheme of the Joker's
goes beyond anything that he's ever done
before it goes beyond any of the schemes
that he's ever had that this is about as
insane as he's gotten or is about as
sadistic as he's gotten and Barbara
Gordon says this for a couple reasons
one because of the look in his eyes but
two because even while she was injured
he had stripped her naked and then
taking pictures of her and so what we do
is we pick up with the Joker and we pick
up with Jim Gordon and Joker's henchmen
and what's happening here is that Jim
Gordon appears to be in the process of
being stripped naked of course of
putting a collar on its neck was
attached at some kind of a chain and Jim
Gordon seems to be waking up as this is
happening now Jim Gordon initially tries
to struggle he tries to get away but of
course he's subdued by the henchman and
the henchman once they've managed to
West chip and completely naked take him
out into the onto the grounds of the
funhouse and put him in front of the
Joker now this entire time Jim Gordon
thinks that maybe he's going crazy maybe
he's losing his mind that he's dreaming
or something like that and the Joker
says no the Joker says the Jim Gordon is
having the same kind of reaction that
any sane person would have under these
particular circumstances that Jim Gordon
is simply just going mad here and so
what he does is he begins I guess poking
fun or begins addressing Jim Gordon
directly and what the Joker is saying it
what he's basically I giving this giving
us the idea of is that in the end that
life is absolutely insane that life has
no real rhyme or reason that things
simply just happen and then people sane
people by the very nature try to
substitute logic where none exists and
as a result as far as the Joker is
concerned there's simply just one bad
day away from losing their minds
entirely and so what we do here is we
jump back to the Joker's past once again
and the Joker of course who's continuing
to address these criminals is visited by
a patrol officer and a detective and
what happens is the Joker initially
thinks that maybe the detective and the
the officer are onto what's going going
to happen and they somehow picked up on
what the plan is of the Joker and these
criminals but what they do is they take
the Joker outside and so what takes
place here is the people with officers
tell Joker that his wife has been killed
in an accident that she had somehow
managed to uh slip and fall and as a
result both her and by extension their
newborn baby is dead and so the Joker
takes this by surprise he's immediately
shocked by this and he goes back inside
and when he does he tells the the
criminals what had happened here and he
tells them that his wife died his wife
in general was the motivation for his
actions that he wanted to be a
respectable husband and a father but
because he will be neither both there's
no reason for him to continue with this
but the criminals say no the criminals
say the Joker is in now and there's no
way for the Joker to leave if he chooses
to leave then he's going to be killed
and so the Joker says okay and he goes
through with a plan and so what we do is
we jump back to Jim Gordon as he's being
taken through this I guess this
torturous roller coaster but the roller
coaster is designed at torture his mind
because what's going on here is the
Joker is subjecting him to all kinds of
insane propaganda to all kinds of insane
screens where he's singing an insane
song any as Jim Gordon is continuing to
this roller coaster he ultimately comes
along the pictures that that the Joker
had taken of Barbara Gordon while she
was while she was injured and and naked
and these pictures again serve the
purpose of tormenting Jim Gordon of
basically giving Jim Gordon a push that
will send him over the edge and into the
realm of insanity and so what we do is
we pick up with Batman here and Batman
is going about the city of Gotham
putting the screws to anybody who may
have any kind of information about where
the Joker might be located or about
where the Joker is what his plan is
but again anyone that might have any
information is certainly not coming
forward here they're simply
not talking but what Batman does is he
sees that the bat signal has been sent
up and so when he arrives he meets with
Harvey Bullock and Harvey Bullock
presents him with a ticket to the to the
Joker's I guess as carnival as well as a
card from the Joker which basically is
an invite to the Batman telling the
Batman that the Joker wants him to be
there and so what happens we pick back
up again with the Joker and and Jim
Gordon and of course at this point Jim
Gordon's rollercoaster ride is over
and Jim Gordon seems to be driven to the
absolute brink of madness here he hasn't
necessarily crossed the edge but he's
certainly a succumbing to the things
that he's seen and again what's going on
is the Joker's commenting on this
insanity The Joker is commenting on the
fact that Jim Gordon doesn't seem to
have given up that he doesn't seem to
have a given end to madness and so the
Joker says that Jim Gordon needs to be
taken back to his cage and that he'll be
subjected to this entire sequence once
again at a later point in time and so as
things continue we jump back to the past
of the Joker again and what we find is
that the Joker and these criminals have
arrived at this this chemical factory
and what happens is one of the criminals
takes out the helmet of the Red Hood and
what they tell the Joker is that the
entire basis of this hood is that it
will keep the Joker's identity protected
that he will be able to guide them
through the chemical plant and that no
one will know who the Joker is and so as
the Joker is taking them through we see
that as security has apparently been
beefed up in the sense that a police
officer sees them and tells them to
freeze now the criminals initially get
angry here they believe the Joker had
lied to them but again as the Joker
tells them he didn't realize the
security had been increased that it must
have been increased in the time since
he's been gone and so what happens in
the ensuing gunfight and the chaos is
the police calls for the police officer
calls for backup but that the criminals
are also killed in the process
and so the Joker is apparently the only
one here but what also takes place is
the Joker I guess this group is
addressed as a Red Hood gang and this is
the entire concept behind this this is
what the criminals had been doing the
criminals have been going about and they
have been enlisting other people under
the guise that their identities will
remain safe but in reality these
individuals were being duped into boat
or I guess into playing the role of the
leader of the Red Hood gang which was
something they of course had been doing
unaware of that
the fact that that was happening and so
what happens is that while the Joker is
trying to get away is he's panicking and
trying to run that Batman shows up
now as the COS refer to him the Batman
or I guess the human bat they don't know
who he is so this is must bear I guess
must be at the very early point of
Batman's career this is probably this
probably predates Batman issue number
one which of course we had seen in
Batman's continuity as the first time
that the Joker had appeared in Batman so
I would go as far as to say this appears
sometime between Detective Comics and
Batman issue number one but nonetheless
what we see is that the Joker who again
is panicking here tells Batman to back
away and that if Batman to another back
away that he's going to jump now whether
or not the Red Hood actually jumps over
or Falls has really left to speculation
here but what we know is that the Joker
ends up in this giant vat of chemicals
and when he comes out when he crawls out
after I guess escaping through a sewer
drain but he takes off the helmet and he
looks at his face in the water and what
he sees is that his hair is turned green
that his face is turned completely white
and that his lips are red which of
course this is basically us learning
this is how the Joker came into
existence but what the Joker is going to
do is he's effectively going to retcon
this origin later on in this story and
so what we do here is we pick up with
the Joker at his carnival as he's
speaking with or speaking about Jim
Gordon and what's taking place here is
the Joker has Jim Gordon in a cage and
he's basically putting Jim Gordon on as
some kind of a sideshow attraction here
he simply refers to Jim Gordon as the
average man that he's he's basically
overweight that he is not very
exceptional that in the end he's
basically optimistic of the fact that
maybe a life will somehow work out for
him that maybe things will work out in
such a way to where this will come out
in his favor that is to say the Joker
will be taken into custody and so on and
so forth but he asked the question how
is it that Jim Gordon is able to live in
this kind of world when there is no real
reason or or rhyme for why it is that
things happen that things simply just
take place what the Joker says is the
only sensible way as far as we have seen
or I guess referencing back to to the
Joker from The Dark Knight the only
sensible way to live in this world is
without reason is without logic and to
live in a realm of madness to live any
other way would be absolutely crazy and
so what happens is that while the Joker
is
I guess we'd be tying or I guess while
he's out going on about Jim Gordon that
Batman arrives and what we get is this
really cool throwback to the beginning
of the Killing Joke where we see Batman
who believed that he was addressing the
Joker speaking with him and saying that
he had come here to talk that he had
gone to Arkham Asylum to speak with the
Joker that he had been thinking about
both the Joker and himself about the
road that they were leading to and that
in the end this will move like most
likely lead to the death of one or both
of them and so what the Joker does is he
runs into the funhouse but Batman goes
to attend to Jim Jim Gordon and the fear
that Batman has here is that maybe Jim
Gordon's given in the Navy Jim Gordon
has fallen off the deep end and he is
given into his own insanity well what
Jim Gordon says is that this is not the
case that that he is not given into his
insanity that he that the Joker try to
drive him mad but in the end it didn't
work and so what Batman says is he's
going to go in and he's going to going
to deal with the Joker but I'm sorry
that he's going to stay with Jim Gordon
but Jim Gordon says no Jim Gordon says
the Batman has to go in and he has to
find the Joker but Batman has to do it
the right way he has to do it by the
book because what it'll do is it'll show
the Joker that their way works that the
word the way of Jim Gordon the way a
Batman works like it should and so what
happens is Batman enters the the
funhouse and the Joker begins speaking
with the Batman he begins talking to him
over an intercom and what the Joker says
is that he's been successful in making
Jim Gordon go insane that that was the
entire basis of all of this the entire
scheme the Joker getting out of Arkham
Asylum a shooting Barbara Gordon of
putting a Jim Gordon to this entire
ordeal was basically to prove the point
that one person the most sane person can
lose their minds entirely if they have
one bad day and this is the theme of The
Killing Joke one bad day this is the
theme of not just The Killing Joke but
the theme of Batman himself and this is
something that the Joker will address
directly the Joker says that he believes
Batman had had one bad day now again the
Joker doesn't know the identity of
Batman being Bruce Wayne but because of
the fact that Joker is saying this and
because we know the other half of this
equation that Batman is Bruce Wayne we
know the Joker is right here that Batman
had one bad day as a child and as a
result he had basically as we perceive
it to be lost his mind entirely became a
became the Caped Crusader dressing up as
a bat and running around in the night
villains and so what the Joker does here
is he says that he too had had one bad
day and this is what I was referring to
in the sense of Joker would retcon his
own origin in the same story the Joker
says that sometimes he remembers his
origin one way and this sometimes he
remembers it another but this is the
kicker here this is really the funny
thing about The Killing Joke we don't
know if the origin that was being given
to us in The Killing Joke was the Joker
remembering his origin or we don't know
if that was the origin that was being
given to us by Alan Moore the Joker says
that perhaps there was a circumstance
where he lived one life perhaps there
was a circumstance where he lived
another but that if he's going to have
his own origin he would prefer that it
be multiple choice and so what happens
here is that as that Batman and the
Joker continue I guess the Joker
continues to talk to Batman and Batman
continues to try to pursue the Joker
the Batman ultimately finds him and
Batman smashes through the window and so
what happens here is Batman throws the
Joker out of the window and then begins
advancing on him now of course the Joker
tries to use the same needle on Batman
that he had used on the carnival owner
but Batman is of course able to to throw
it away now what we also see is that the
Joker grabs the mask of Batman and pulls
it down and this is what I love about
the Joker the Joker is physically
ill-equipped to go toe-to-toe with the
Batman he simply just can't fight the
Batman in hand-to-hand combat and so he
does what any desperate man would do to
overcome his foe he uses what's around
him he simply grabs a two-by-four after
pulling Batman's mask over his head and
smashed him over the head with his
two-by-four and so again he pulls a
knife he tries to attack Batman with a
knife but Batman is able to overcome him
and able to punch him in the gut and
subdue him and so what happens is that
as both Batman and the Joker are
basically in this circumstance that
Batman tries to again extend an olive
branch to to the Joker he tells the
Joker that the row that they're both
walking this path or leading is going to
lead to the death of one or both of them
and so he says that he can take the
Joker in that he can try to rehabilitate
the Joker he can try to give the Joker
back to back to his sane ways or the
very least make him more sane than he is
now but the Joker says no the Joker says
it is too late for that he says that his
situation reminds him of a funny joke
and this I think is one of the coolest
coolest parts of the entire killing joke
because what this does is again
highlight the similarities and just how
similar Batman is between the Joker and
himself and what the Joker says is that
there were two men and in a sane asylum
in a lunatic asylum and that one night
they decided they didn't want to live in
this Asylum anymore and so they wanted
to escape to freedom and so what they
did is once they got to the roof of the
of the the insane asylum they had seen
between a short gap in themselves was
freedom they could simply jump this gap
and they could run over the buildings
and escape and so what happened is the
first person the first man jumped over
the gap onto the next building but the
second man didn't want to do it and he
didn't do it because he was afraid that
if he did he might fall through the gap
and so what the first man does is he
says that he will extend he will use his
flashlight and extend a bridge and so
the second man says that he's not going
to walk along this bridge and when the
first man asks why the second man says
because the first man will turn off the
flashlight and this is really funny here
because what happens is Batman actually
laughs at this joke and again the entire
basis behind this joke more so than it
being a joke is that it's a parable a
parable being that only an insane man
would believe that a flashlight could
make a physical bridge that he could
walk across because again the fear of
the second man was that the first man
would turn off the flashlight which in
turn would remove the bridge now as this
comic begins to come to a close one
question that I would ask you here one
thing that I'd like to know on your
opinions is how do you think The Killing
Joke really ends how do you think the
relationship exists between the Batman
and the Joker with that being said I'm
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace